he is Britain's first Muslim Home
Secretary
but Sajid Javid has also prompted a
pledge to hold an inquiry into
Islamophobia in the Tory Party did your
good guys should we should we have an
external investigation the cassette of
party into cell phobia so they were an
unexpected and good moment given that
prime ministerial favourite Boris
Johnson last year said Muslim women
wearing burkas look like bank robbers
and letterboxes comments which have now
been brought up again in the Commons the
member has called Muslim women
letterboxes described African people we
know several dozen people have been
suspended from the Tory party but the
conservative Muslim forum told us there
is no transparent data on Islamophobia
and that repeated requests to gather it
have been ignored the Muslim Council of
Britain gave evidence to the Home
Affairs Select Committee on Islamophobia
last week it was very critical of the
Tory Party we have seen unequivocally
failures within the specifically
conservative party when it comes to
Islamophobia not just small failures
fundamental failures of in every single
way Nasim Yousuf once stood as a Tory
Party candidate in the local elections
in West London
she is sceptical of the promise of an
inquiry they want to show that we are
not prejudiced we are bringing Muslims
forward but in heart of their heart or
you know sort of they know that they are
not giving them any favor they are just
showing people that you know to the
public that you know Salathe
but they try to give you an opportunity
opportunity but then they gave me a tuna
t4 receipt which was not winnable many
community leaders say any such inquiry
should go much further and look at
Islamophobia in all political parties
and across society as a whole but the
credibility of an inquiry will be
affected by whoever gets the top job in
the Tory party visa Holland sky knees